a la vista ortiz espinoza usted
participó días pasados de una sesión en
la cámara de los comunes en canadá allí
en la sede parlamentaria en ottawa puede
comentarnos de qué se trató este evento
y ésta es una pasada del marzo 5 a 8 yo
participé en el área de road o hija del
botón que es una iniciativa muy
ambiciosa y que se creó para estirar y
bien poder a dar a las mujeres que
participen más en la política y yo
representa en el distrito federal
ranking sánchez en la cámara de los
comunes este distrito se encuentra en la
provincia de ontario
y el eje de su participación en que
estuvo centrado
lo que yo quisiera es para nosotros
relegar a aprender de las políticas
mujeres para aprender que hacen día a
día oímos de muchos políticos senadoras
y también de los líderes de todos los
palacios de canadá entonces escuchando
de el primer ministro su lado y de
muchas muchas muchas personas que nos
hablaron y nos dijeron mucho de lo que
hacen y a usted le interesa ese mundo de
la política
si me interesa porque yo estudié
ciencias políticas y entonces me gusta
toda la política del gobierno y también
de ayudar a mi comunidad
está dentro de sus objetivos el de
dedicarse el día de mañana a la política
bueno primeramente me lo que quiero
hacer es convertirme en una abogada para
mi comunidad pero también me gustaba
mucho la política entonces siempre es
algo que hago por voluntariados o por
cosas así
y dentro de esa actividad de la política
hay alguna cuestión algún tema alguna
área específica que a usted le atraiga
más y a mí me interesa mucho la tema de
los inmigrantes en canadá entonces esta
semana pasada yo hablé en el comité de
inmigración y ciudadanía y hablé del
racismo que sufren las comunidades
inmigrantes en canadá y las comunidades
étnicas así como de la falta de apoyos
para los inmigrantes durante la pandemia
y siendo the brain tienes una ciudad muy
diversa una de las más diversas y canadá
yo siempre veo lo que lo que pasa día a
día y considero que esta diversidad es
algo muy hermosa e integral y ser
sagrada y entonces yo pienso que se debe
proteger y el racismo sistémico debe de
parar aquí y es lo que haré en el comité
usted sabe a la lista esta expresión del
racismo sistémico
no es del todo entendida aún por algunas
personas en el caso específico de su
jurisdicción del lugar en el cual usted
vive y al cual usted representó ese
racismo sistémico de qué manera se
expresa si para el racismo no es siempre
de personas directamente a otras
personas a veces en las instituciones
que están creadas
lo que hay presente en las ciudades y
eso es lo que crea ese racismo sistémico
es algo que no sé de nuestra persona a
persona entonces es muy difícil de parar
y por eso tiene que ir a la política y
tiene que cambiar la política
y así así el racismo el sistémico
ahora más allá de la diversidad desde la
jurisdicción que usted representa usted
es nacida en canadá no es inmigrante
pero sus padres si fueron en su momento
inmigrantes es así
si yo no estoy aquí pero mis padres
vinieron de panamá y siempre me
enseñaron de todas las culturas panameña
y me enseñaron que cuando vinieron no
era tan fácil fue un poco difícil pero
ellos hasta los muy duros
con tiempo ellos han logrado muchísimo
cuál fue la razón por la que sus padres
decidieron dejar su panamá natal y venir
a canadá
bueno cuando ellos estaban allá en los
80s
el líder noriega
estaba en poder y entonces mis padres
pensaron que en canadá ellos tenían más
oportunidades y entonces ellos vinieron
aquí y yo nací aquí ustedes actualmente
en que se desempeña alanís
y ahorita mismo yo estoy estudiando
leyes en la universidad de lastra en el
reino unido y también estoy trabajando
en una firma en donde hago mucho trabajo
en el departamento legal y también soy
la editora en jefe de la revista de mi
universidad
y esa ese bagaje esa experiencia de
formación
[Música]
de ahí de acción inclusive que usted ya
tiene reunida en su corta vida a través
de su formación en ciencias políticas y
ahora en su estudio de leyes de qué
manera la piensa volcar cuál es el lg en
el cual se centraría su su próxima
actividad profesional si yo quiero
enfocarme a ir a mi comunidad y más
específicamente en mi comida latina aquí
en franzini en toronto y por eso quiero
estudiar leyes para que puedo ayudar a
mi comunidad en treme de inmigración y
entrenos de todo lo que necesita mi
familia o de lo que esté aquí ahora
estará ahí aquí para toda mi comunidad y
creo que
por estudiar leyes eso me va a ayudar
mucho usted nombró al comienzo de
nuestra conversación al tema de la
pandemia de qué manera ha afectado la
pandemia a la comunidad inmigrante en su
jurisdicción
sí bueno muchos de los inmigrantes que
vinieron tuvieron que conseguir muy
vulnerables que no les ofrecen
beneficios y que de verdad no tienen
mucho apoyo del gobierno y entonces
muchos han sufrido y muchos han
están con el código y necesitan mucha
ayuda del gobierno cree que la política
es una herramienta eficaz para ayudar a
esa gente si piensa que si piensa que de
él están más hispanos y latinas a la
cámara de los comunes y eso es algo que
yo aprendido y que quiero hacer también
creo que un día entonces usted se ve en
el futuro como la legisladora canadiense
si piensas que si en más en el futuro
viví en el futuro muy lejano o cercano
tal vez después que me gradué de derecho
alanís muchísimas gracias por esta
entrevista con radio que nada
internacional
muchas gracias luis